my name is Abdullah and the title of
this presentation when i submitted you
months ago computer science in
mathematica its building parsers
generator it's a mathematic of is
actually more toward the computer
science and mathematics and more about
how to program Mathematica packages how
to go about you know writing complicated
piece of code and the motivating example
is going to be a parser generator that's
completely done and not good so this
talk of us about you know one thing and
you know that's something that you all
have in common which is you know when
you have a piece of code it quickly
becomes a very complicated project and
so the south is going to motivate how to
manage this complexity by describing
this simple parser generator so
complexity arises because either you
know it's a hard problem to solve and
you know we're not going to deal with
that you know another reason is this
because it's kind of hard to express on
a computer you know computers are bits
and bytes and all of that then you just
want to say turn left and right you
don't want to know type in all this crap
you know the other one is you're not
thinking about the problem very well so
you haven't like sat down in room
without with a pen and paper and just
wrote everything out you just serve what
popped on the keyboard started typing
your print nothing all that so and you
might not have a good foundation or a
good tool so you might be using the
wrong tools you're not you know if you
have a problem with serve managing
source code you know where to put your
source code how to have revisions and
you're probably now using stuff like get
or CBS you know you might not be using
an ID like eclipse certain your work
venture eclipse or Visual Studio and the
other one
you know you've written all this code
but you really don't understand what
you've written so the codes is doing one
thing you have your own logic and that
the code has its own different logic so
there are ways to sort of you know deal
with that so I i think the programmers
you know you should start by think about
the problem away from the computer yo a
computer is just for typing you know the
program should be developed somewhere in
your head you want a piece of paper and
you should be spinning you should be
spending a few hours or a few days
trying to think about what you're
actually going to write researching what
others have done so people you know
might have spent a year you know think
about this problem vs you only have you
eight or ten hours to think about it and
you can use those for inspiration or
techniques and you know maybe you could
figure out you know maybe that's not a
problem after or maybe you find like a
library somebody has out has developed
something you're ready so you just use
their code versus you know develop
everything from scratch maybe you can
define you'll find like there's a
mathematical function that already does
it and usually you know there's 5,000 or
6,000 symbols you found that I mean I
usually find a lot of you know stuff
that I usually want to do by just
searching the help page I don't know any
I don't know most of the symbols so
that's usually helpful okay so so you
can also have not not have a good
foundation of the tool so a lot of times
you when you start a project you you
know start from the top down yo you're
defying you want to define your problem
but sometimes it's much better to start
by having a good foundation especially
if it's a huge project you know having
good debugger your debugging statement
having a logger you know having unit
tests those are very very important to
start developing those from the
beginning and that's how you could
manage complexity
so go to the main are the top which is a
parser generator so who knows hear what
the parser generator is okay so parser
generator just so you give it grammar so
you know you give it a language grammar
and it's going to find if the string you
pass it in is an instance of that
grammar so you essentially give it you
know tokens that could produce different
strings and then you're just saying you
is my string could it be possibly
generated by those tokens so one example
is you know Mathematica you know exper
you know could be just said you know
it's a it's an identifier followed by
some brackets followed by a sequence of
expertise so you know you could probably
you probably use them all the time so
regular expressions are example of
parser generators so string match q is
actually you know is doing it its is
creating a regular expression here is
trying to match it against this so this
is saying there's zero or more a's in
that string is asking that question the
canister is yes so so it's actually
could be represented so me worth boy so
it's actually represented by a finite
state automaton where you start by you
start at the start node and then for all
a's you know if you see an a then you go
to be a nodes and then you sort of loop
over until you accept in the end note
and you know the famous examples of
these are you know Lex and yak they sort
of you and just pass it in a bunch of
rules and it's going to generate a huge
C code for you hopefully I may probably
use them you just don't know that may
that Matthew a lot of languages are
defined using so there you know the
programming languages are usually you
know they have your program string then
you're going to use a parser which is
generated by these parser generator
because nobody wants to write this kind
of tedious and to write these parsers by
hand and you don't get anything at you
on a very you know you don't get so much
added value from writing by hand versus
you know just defining at the abstract
level and the program generates it does
then you convert the your string into an
abstract syntax tree which is
essentially the expert in Mathematica
AST then usually code goes to a
low-level representation which is kind
of between the AST and the sort of
machine code then you optimize on that
serve machine independent representation
then you dump machine code you know
assembly or so feel free to like stop me
at any point cuz I realized like oh as I
was putting this presentation is like
this is kind of not too many people so
so the task is like and this is sort of
a very early prototype is you know how
would you define a parser generator
Mathematica so mathematically it has
some nice features but you know
sometimes you want to write your own
sort of language with in Mathematica and
just parse that you know convert that
language into mathematic and execute
that so some examples you know it
finding like domain-specific languages
where you have your own serve syntax
operant you you know it's usually
helpful or REO you could define a you
know define a Python parser and then
convert that into mathematica and
partner you'll excuse the code in
Mathematica so you know if you're given
a language you know if you give it some
language and then you generate the
finite state machine and it executes the
code and accepts or rejects the string
depending on whether it reaches the end
nodes in the state yes yes so this
actually does that also so there's also
these groupings and it could call
dispatch functions depending on what you
know depending on the rules that you
great so so by sort of separating out
the problem in two different arc in
different sections you know so I have I
want to define a parser January so what
the first thing is I have to give it a
language for the parser generator itself
then that would have to be represented
symbolically in Mathematica and then I
could generate the so I'm converting the
rules for the parser to bytecode that
then get optimized and then interpreted
in Mathematica so by sectioning off
these properties i get some kind of
really nice features so the first
feature that kind of nice is you know I
can separate out the virtual machine so
the virtual machine is going to be
defined in Mathematica for now and it's
going to simulate what a computer do so
if there's a branch if there's an if
condition that is going to jump to this
location
going to jump to another location it can
say is like instructions like saving to
save environment jump the option you'll
increment the program counter it's very
very very low level and that's because
you know the chain of instruction can be
complicated so I have this binary
expression which is essentially
identifier plus identifier and this is
sort of the assembly instructions as
being generated so it's going to match
any of these characters and it's going
to do a loop is going to capture
patterns and depending on the pattern my
called a function to find somewhere else
this is going to call the this function
when it reaches a pattern in my faces so
this is this guy's just generated by
going through the symbolic
representation and then the other thing
i could do is generate a graph is the
combat so this is the finest 80 by a
state machine we just say you know the
surf nodes somewhere then i can see the
end node here but then you have to find
where the star code is and from there
what the machine is saying is you know
there is some path from the start node
to the end node given a string
so it's kind of like you know if the
circuit is like way to the last section
so you have to go from here to here
based on the stream so that's just for
your very basic ok so so that's kind of
fun so we defined the virtual machine
abstractly now you know I want to define
the language definition and one of the
interesting things is you don't have to
define you'll be how you're going to
parse the input language you could just
define how the symbolic representation
of the definition so so by defining the
symbolic representation of the
definition I could generate the parser
for the parser language so I could boost
wrap the parser generator so an example
of that is you know by then with these
paths with these patterns I can lower
the instructions to some more basic
primitives so for example zero or more
is the star operator in regular
expressions or dot dot in Mathematica or
you underscore underscore underscore in
patterns that gets translated to this
small binary expression where it's one
or more which is the plus is the same
exact code except there has to be an
occurrence of a at the beginning so I
could just say you know essentially that
means that you know one or more is you
know I could reuse the definitions of
zero or more to define one or more and
then yo optimizations can be done
symbolically for example so if I have
zero or more falls by zero
more then I could just delete this outer
zero more because star star is just the
other star and then the byte codes can
be easily interpreted in Mathematica or
it can be synthesized to see now the
synthesis to see is not done is not
there but it's rather trivially it take
probably a day to define and then by
separating the different parts of the
project I could debug certain sections
so if I have a problem with the
optimizer and could just call the
optimization that I know there's a bug
here because I have not defined vm but I
could pass in parameters to the
optimizer and check you know is it is it
actually functioning correctly is the
lowering stage I can visualize the
lowering stage and say you is actually
generating acceptable code and then in
the sort of code generation stage I can
also pass in the sort of lowering
instruction and generate and serve
during machine level code at that level
so that's usually called separation of
concerns so that's a very very powerful
concept because you know you want
independent pieces of your projects that
interact with each other through a
protocol but don't entirely depend on
what I mean they don't depend on one
another they could take as long as they
take this is you know the expected input
and produce an output then you can
string them together okay so this is the
symbolic definition of these primitive
operators and I have the the UK you
could define it in a string fashion
these symbolic primitives but i'm not
going to show you that so everything in
the symbolic so you have a pattern of a
which means match the string a or
mash this set so set means new or is
pattern of a or you know pattern of you
know if it's a string then it's a
pattern of B or pattern embassy a
sequence is you know they have to follow
each other so a and then be this example
range is you know anything within that
range 0 through 9 ordered means the
ordered choice so it's going to match a
and if a is not match then it's going to
match be that's very different from
stuff like blech zinyak where it's going
to match a or b this says this this is
going to match the only a is not matched
so this is if you're familiar with
parser Combinator's this is a parsing
expression grammar this slightly more
restricted form of a CFG okay a
context-free grammar but actually by
restricting it actually makes certain
classes of problems harder to manifest
nice actually as powerful is sleepy so
zero or more and done one or more are
the patterns and then capture name is
going to capture the pattern and going
to return a rule with that name and the
pattern that's being so I think that's
sort of fairly it's kind of much better
to sort of look at how it actually gets
generated so fight all lower on any of
these and then generate this string so I
call it like so it's called parsing
expression grammar I just replace a p
with it so is it this so the pattern egg
has compiled to match the character a
and then go to the end state if it stops
at any other points it's now we're going
to go through the end state and then
same thing if i do the set pattern and
set that i probably need to put in it
yeah so but like if i go to look at the
bunny how binary expression then x is
generated so that's this is how oh right
rice soup vinick's is right so maybe you
should look at like identifier so
identifier just says you know it could
be either a dollar sign or a character
uppercase character lowercase character
for the first character and then it
could also include zero or more
characters that also include digits and
everything is in line I mean you could
also have you know calls so you can
define define terms and then get those
get links at a later stage so that will
allow you to have recursion so I could
say term you know a term can equal to a
term if I inline them then I have an
infinite recursion but if I do a you
know a set delayed exam then I would get
the you know and then have it a link
step to merge the two parking grammars
so by also using the symbolic
representation I could do some
optimizations quite easily you know is
just pattern matching and rewriting for
example that's zero zero or more zero or
more a so I have a set of rules that
simplify the nodes and then it separates
the language parser from its compiler
and that allows me to define you know
the initial grammar using the this
framework so this is a at the lowering
stage what we do is we could go from the
high-level representation which is these
zero or more or one or more and do some
simplification so for example one or
more of a pattern is equivalent to us
you know and the pattern followed by
zero or more of the same instance so we
do these optimization and then we
generate so we generate the Machine a
virtual machine which has stuff like you
know love a jump table has the certain
properties that are included as a
association and those are the string
representation of that code and this is
not something you can you should
probably read but but I mean for small
example is easy to read if you know this
company's but but you can easily
generate machines this is very very
close to machine instructions I mean
these are go tues and jumps and you know
the other way to deal with complexity
aside from sort of separating out your
project and separate components is by
visualization so identifiers we saw that
so this is the string representation of
an identifier to match on Aon identifier
so to be any of these characters for the
first letter
and then any of these characters or a
digit for the second character and I
could generate a graph from that and
this is sort of how a machine would
execute the code so i go from a stark
know that can match the dollar sign and
if yes and i go to the second step if
know that i have to go check the other
cases and eventually I would have to go
to the end node over here so we're going
to have a small example so we're going
to define a digit which is a range from
0 to 9 and going to define the integer
which is zero or one or more of those
digits so it could be and then we're
going to create a grammar in here that's
going to create a virtual machine and
going to pass the string 2 3 2 1 to it
so if I do that I I get sort of
debugging safer that says tells me like
what the machine is doing and I get you
know the int this this pattern is 2 3 2
1 then I could define a simplified
binary operator okay a simplified binary
operator by having you uh you know an
int plus or minus and other ends and I'm
going to have you left hand side rule in
the right hand side and I want to
capture the operator and I think the
printing it causes it to slow down but
it also has checking a lot of states so
I get the the rules
now one thing that the previous case had
not handle spaces between operators oh I
cannot write 2 3 2 1 space plus so this
rule would not match so just return an
empty string and so I can define a
spacing is a bit more complicated
because let's say I want also to handle
tabs and new line and continue art you
know / r /t character turn that could if
I put those in this spacing in the rule
then I can match you know a space
between the operator
yeah so so you could get you know you
know you you're actually interpreting a
very you know complicated state machine
there's a lot of you know there's a ton
of states in here that you're served in
your checking you know you're not going
through wrong cases you know but you're
backtracking a couple of times so
there's a few things that are not
working so capturing is not entirely
working so this is the if state this is
the definition of an if statement and to
capture that pattern seems to not work
example but yeah so it fails it does not
come doesn't it matches but it does not
capture the patterns that I want for
example I want the conditional
statements and then decided right hand
side and then finally that you know by
using this technique you could separate
each parts of the project and separate
components test them separately and then
you could debug each component on its
own and this might not be efficient to
you know do this sort of you know that
you know there's a lot of assumptions
that have to be computed it recomputed
at each step but these parser generators
don't have to be efficient they have to
just omit efficient code so that's sort
of the trick